welcome back to unsensitive pist Brendan
kavar AKA Dr K was entertaining crowds
at some pan Station in London on the
public piano there when he's approached
by a group of flag waving Chinese
onlookers who demanded he stopped
filming and a shocking twist the police
seem to back the tourists and today the
piano's been mysteriously cordoned off
all very mysterious um it was quite
bizarre Dr K you join me now I watched
the whole video to get a proper context
for this you're just minding your own
business sure you're playing Beautiful
piano as you do you're a very talented
guy thank people are enjoying it and
your stick is they come over and
interact with you and it's great U very
harmless and fun um and this is a un
action I mean fantastic but then this
group Chinese people in the background
with their with their Flags yes come
over and sort of believe they have the
right to stop you filming and doing what
you're let listen to what happened okay
this is our right to where we're
protecting and that's it but what right
I don't understand son image right we
are protecting our own image right
you're not sharing but this we're in
public yeah exactly but we're in a free
country mate that's true communist China
now you know oh I'm sorry this is recent
now we have no we're not in communist
China we're in a free country got a
Chinese flag it doesn't matter show me
the Chinese flag why you're touching her
stop touching her don't touch her please
do not touch her please you are not the
same age please do not touch her don't
touch her it was totally bizarre he got
very Ang that guy but I also thought the
police woman who would came over to you
I didn't like what she was doing either
which is almost acquiescing to this well
absolutely she completely took the side
of the Chinese because they mentioned
the RW um racist uh she melted like a
jelly and and nothing you said was
racist at all well I I think she said
her her beef with me was that I said
we're I said we're not in China now yeah
and she found that an extremely
offensive phrase because she said that
would hurt the feelings of the Chinese
around the piano and you can hear her
Whispering you can't say that and I said
what and she said you can't say we're
not in China now I said that's a factual
statement and I think when the police
deal with these politically correct
issues they're all over the place
because they think they're going to
offend someone and so she took it out on
me she thought she was I suppose virtue
signaling signaling to her Masters and
uh but she didn't is they were filming
themselves some kind of commercial sure
and they were also filming me it's been
pointed out if you actually watch the
video there's a guy in a gimbal from
from the CCP uh uh group that was there
who was constantly filming me one of the
girls was filming me but they said I
wasn't allowed to film them and that I
needed to delete my footage because they
had uh a disclaimer that no one was
allowed to film them in the station it B
what's it's really hit a nerve over six
million people and they watch this
online you probably never had a reaction
quite likly well no and also I've got to
tell you I've just before I came in pi
I've just had a phone call the video is
on the verge of being taken down by
YouTube because I've had a second strike
against it so someone does not want this
video to be taken uh doesn't want this
video to be there um it's about to be
taken down so if anyone's watching this
please download it and if the video
disappears um obviously pressure has
been put on YouTube to what does it tell
you about where we are with free speech
in the world right ah well this whole
thing was a mini parable about the value
of Free Speech it was a spontaneous live
stream um we were attempted to be shut
down um but in the end Free Speech
prevailed and I think that's why it's
got such a lot of traction around the
world because where do you see free
speech prevailing in in a little mini
drama um and that's what happened they
walked away free speech prevailed but
now they want to take the video down the
video is on the verge of being taken
down please if you're watching this
download the video and if the video gets
taken down let's kick up a stink how did
did the police end up with you over the
whole thing they called the there was
about five of them and one of the one of
the group went and got the police and
said that we've got here a violent Thug
who is threatening us and is calling us
Communists and uh we feel threatened and
he also needs to delete his footage and
uh the police lady immediately took
their side and uh she gave me quite a
hard time she told me I couldn't say
things she said to stop filming no I
watched it I was I couldn't understand
what she was doing
oh I knew what you were do understand it
either P you know what reaction have you
I mean have you been back since to play
the piano uh no my my friend Terry I've
got a good friend my friend Terry miles
God bless him he was there today he's a
he's a fantastic uh YouTuber he was
there today and there was e even a
protest today supporting the piano and
Me in St Pancras free the piano Terry
was there today the piano's back and I
think the when are you back
there I don't know if I should saping
yes you should do you think I should go
back ad absolutely give me your will you
come with me back tomorrow morning you
reckon yes you reckon of course you'll
be a superstar now you re you bigger
crowds than Elton John who I think I
think donated the piano didn't he he did
and elton's team has been contacted by
The Daily Express to give a comment on
the fact that the piano was shut off um
but when they heard that they actually
released the piano so it's back in use
again but um when are you going back
come on give me a scoop PE PE PE don't
know if I can I Free Speech spit it out
ma'am I might go on Friday Friday this
Friday what kind of time are people are
in town peer PE I want to cause a
commotion PE Pier you're you're you're
stirring this up man you're you're
stirring this anyone from the Communist
Party in China is watching this look I
can't tell you when he's performing but
it's Friday look MI5 have told me to
keep a low I'm only J I'm only joking
but look I I'm I may be there on Friday
but you know it's it's a it's a
sensitive situation um the police
British transport police have freaked
out St panras have freaked out but
people have you know what they should
all just calm down and recognize we live
last time I checked in a free Democratic
country and you are allowed to play the
piano where you've played it many times
we got to leave it there great to see
you Brendon all the best get down in pan
because we're all behind you that's it
from me whatever you're up to Keep It
Uncensored especially from the
Communists in God bless you
pleas